one of the funniest guys out there I
loved having him on NFL draft Athan last
week as well his show the neighborhood
Season 2 currently airing Mondays on CBS
at 8:00 Eastern Time and you can catch
not one but two episodes airing
back-to-back tonight starring at 8:00
Eastern Time he is Cedric the
Entertainer how are you sir Rich Eisen
what's up brother how are you doing I'm
good good you know just being the corona
corona safe at the house and uh can't
complain I appreciate that everybody
happy and healthy and you're in your
world hopefully then yeah you bet you
bet are you watching any of this Jordan
documentary I am of course man I'm now
I'm actually behind on these two bad air
okay this weekend so I have to record it
but I will jump in but it was a
interesting are you talking to Barkley
earlier yeah and I actually was one of
my most interesting moments with
gambling with the both of them I'm
hanging with Charles in Vegas and we're
gambling and then MJ walks in and grabs
like a handful of Charles chips it chars
like whoa whoa what you doing this how
much was that MJ looks at here we go
does it matter like I've got it bro like
whatever it is I've got it built you
wouldn't you think it yeah of course
I mean so it was this at a blackjack
table or something play everywhere we
were playing along it was like being
Carson Daly I said we were having a good
time we were playing along Charles and
then Jordan with the play blackjack came
back probably 40 minutes later and just
handed him one hundred fifty two hundred
fifty thousand dollars and chips and
said I'm up over here I'm up over this
table and then we all would got a blip
Charles and with the plane to go and
punch my GoPro blackjack although I
would be afraid to play blackjack with
him because if you like if you're like
one of those that hits on 12 or hits on
13 and he's not I mean I would have to
look at him and say you what do you want
me to Michael I would never
oh my god that's pressure
for sure we I didn't I didn't I played
along with Charles but I did not play in
the game with Michael Jordan his
mistakes were lightweight
well so I guess the the ultimate button
on this story is that it ultimately did
not matter how much that dude like on
the basketball court and it blackjack
attached I mean and then of course what
what Jordan meant so if we're talking
about right now I mean you must have
been talking about late 90s or something
like that right when somewhat this
happened because we were all there for
Tiger Woods so okay golf event but we
were all just kind of hanging out in
Vegas so that that was one of those you
know great moments here for sure I mean
and Jordan so are you a fan of any
specific team I know you're from
Missouri originally so what are you the
Bulls of my team all my you know all my
basketball you know stuff that I have
jerseys rope that I wear around the
house it has all the Bulls because from
st. Louis that was our quickest and
closest professional team so I could
jump on a plane and go to the games and
you know in doing those errors of course
it was just that it was the best best
team to go and watch and in Chicago was
a was an exciting city for st. Louis ins
to get to we can drive here for hours of
flight air in 45 minutes on the little
Southwest so that was uh that was our
that was like Adam our Los Angeles the
Vegas trip if you will know it was our
kind of experience I'm telling you
Cedric I mean subject the entertainer
here in the Rich Eisen show again I'm
not spoiling anything from last night
what's sitting on your DVR those two
episodes from last night
I mean they do get in at one point about
what a rock concert it was in terms of
trying to get tickets for the last dance
years or just in terms for Jordan
anywhere on the road or at home and what
it meant and how Chicagoans and people
from you know Chicagoland or from what
you're pointing out st. Louis or Bulls
country how its we may never see
anything like that again and I
understand with LeBron
with the warriors of the comet cetera
but there's nothing quite like those
Jordan Bulls no doubt it probably would
like you rich in both teams that were
unlike the town of LeBron phenomenon
would be the closest and of course when
go to state was just in that frenzy have
just went in and you know everywhere
they showed up would be a circus but
nothing was like Jordan could think they
could pull this kind of energy anywhere
in the country wherever he showed up it
would be the craziest night in town
everybody's gonna show up it's gonna be
big you know I'd like it to Mike Tyson
look the old Mike Tyson fights like it
was the best of the best everybody's
gonna come you're gonna put on your best
you're gonna party the hardest you're
gonna watch it's gonna be exciting and
that's gonna that's the attitude when
the MJ would show up yeah and
unfortunately for many that he was
competing against just like Tyson fights
if you missed the first two minutes it
was over you had a bulls robe
I got a beautiful robe Mansell would do
for being with the you know the great
Bulls you know rotary on it it's so good
okay I like that Cedric the Entertainer
here again the neighborhood currently
airing Mondays on CBS starring in part
this gentleman right here on the Rich
Eisen show on we'll get to that in a
second I the original Kings of Comedy
it's interesting too you're gonna see
some spike in the last dance from from
Sunday night because of you know he was
mars blackmon and we talked about
Jordans Nike commercials and how spike
was the director and so much of a
creative force behind all about what was
it like with Spike for the original
Kings of Comedy you were one of the four
hilarious
stand-up acts that were featured in that
film spike I think you know he killed it
came a boy to shoot the tour we had been
you know touring around the country
probably several years before we decided
to shoot the movie and you know he saw
it in New York and that came probably
like the same way that he kind of saw it
Jordan
he saw this as a piece of culture and a
piece of like a real Americana that he
to be captured and shot in a way that he
could tell you this story and I think
that's the way that he did the Jordan
phenomenon and but captured it in the
shoes and and you know it was one of
these things there again one of the
biggest you know catchphrases that we've
ever heard and advertising there's got
to be the shoes it's got to be the shoes
you know and in that partnership that he
had those like kind of commercials to
see little girl Spike Lee so smaller
begins Jordan and then that unlikely
friendship between him is character mars
blackmon indium j-just not coming I feel
like it led to so many other you know
images including the Geico lizard now
they think that's all part of this whole
starting from Mars so what was it like
being on that tour your you know known
another Chicago guy riding Bernie yeah
right on yeah buddy magley Bernie Mac
man uh I mean it was the first time you
know so many individual comics have been
out and you know that you know did large
arena tours you know Eddie Murphy and
Dice Clay and Martin Lawrence that I can
recall before us but nobody get quite
you know decided to do it as for guys
that show up like for your favorites and
it kind of shows up in a rock star
status so for us it was rock star comedy
man we we toured the country it was
great you know celebrity driven people
will come up in each city I was me I
wouldn't marry their first those girls
and everything and then I got married
and it changed in I bad I'm sure it was
you know when we mentioned it you were
four you zoomed in on NFL draft a thon
live and you were and you were in a car
and Kevin Hart was was in his home
office and he widened his shot out and
there was a there's a beautiful painting
of Bernie Mac I mean he was it that
painting was on his office wall you know
being like for me he would actually I
would go first and it so and then it
would be this brief intermission and so
Burnie did his show one night and then
after the my university came into my
dressing room and performed for my
guests like he just you know impromptu
came in and did this whole other said he
did a red fox impersonation with
hilarious and then and it's turn around
like back out and just walked out it was
just like what it's still one of
greatest legendary moments of comedy
like nobody expected it he just came in
and killed the room and he was like that
like after the show he was just gonna go
do his own thing he wasn't you know I
have to party go hang out guy so he do a
show be a great friend and then he'd go
up and be in the Macworld just gonna
keep the quiet and simple
yes sure and and steve harvey we had him
on at the super bowl because he's the
host of NFL honors and my my audio
executive Mike del 2fo said that that
Steve Harvey would remember him working
with him it kind of looked like Steve
was putting on airs that he remembered
Mike just completely apropos of nothing
eccentric if you could handicap that do
you think he actually did remember Mike
or he put on airs and he remembered Mike
what do you think you know it's people
did a lot of stuff in Chicago during
that time as well so yeah he exactly
just figure all that deal hugely it was
I mean that was a great time obviously
for you and your career and how it's all
built up to everything then all your
success so tell me about their
neighborhood what you enjoyed doing this
show that season two back-to-back shows
tonight we were about to do a three show
article of course the caloric a minute
stop the last episode was really great
is that we had so much fun on the show
the show is about a white family moving
into a predominantly black neighborhood
so this justification had attitude of
you know how does America learn to get
along with people who kind of feels that
they know someone doesn't belong but now
you got to be neighbors and
so the first season was where we it was
hard and I was a little gruff and and
you know I made them kind of earning and
in this season you see us become
friendlier and then even closer even
closer friends as the season goes along
and yet dave still makes them over steps
or so played by Matt Groening field in
these last two episodes he has a you
know a near-death experience problems
getting hit by a speeding car the
neighborhood he gets everyone signed
petitions that get a speeding block put
up put up and that fires him up to just
be more acidic than ever and tries this
now he's gonna run for City Council it
so I'm like bro that's way too soon you
just got here nobody's gonna vote for
you but you know he's over these
overzealous and go for it is so the
first episode Kevin set up in the second
episode tonight we see Dave gearing up
his office campaign and you know and
trying to get me to come on and help him
out and be his campaign manager and he
has the run of being be the who's moving
come to play by Wayne Brady so we got
fun episodes and now it kind of ends in
a cliffhanger because you don't know
what happens
yeah with day we we had the third
episode where you can kind of see what
happens but now you have no idea if he's
gonna win or not and I think that that's
pretty cool well another another
while we need to get through all this
real quick is to see more work from you
sir
I appreciate the call I've said you're
one of my favorites and I'm thrilled to
have you on here and anytime you just
want to you know shoot the you know what
talk sports
all right preciate it before the great
show - thank you I read a little bit
right back at you that's Cedric the guy
Cedric the Entertainer right here in the
Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here